okay so that's the first section on what
DevOps is about now each section has got
a knowledge check so I need to ask you
to putting it in the chat what the
answer you think it's so what is gold
plating is it writing complicated code
making user interface especially
appealing work which has little or no
value or writing to my texts okay I'm
seeing agencies quite a lot of those
well the answer is actually see work
which has little or no value although a
is actually kind partially correct
actually because complicated code
suggests that you've done too much work
okay
I always differentiate between complex
and complicated code maybe need to
become complex to solve problems
complicated code is does something in a
very messy way that's over over
engineered if you like and there's no
need to do that keep it simple okay so
now let's look at the technical
challenges so technical challenges are
constant because everything's constantly
changing
this is probably the most dynamic
business you can be in some things like
some of the sciences things don't change
very much in terms of IT things change
very very frequently we get new
technologies and new ideas one
interesting thing about with maybe
interesting thing about software
development is what a good practice is
what were good practices five years ago
are now considered bad practices which
is quite interesting so the challenges
technology is constantly changing isn't
it we're getting better and better
hardware it's faster it's cheaper
it can do so much more stuff it's
amazing what power you've got think
about a mobile phone that is incredibly
kept that powerful computer it's got a
lot of memories or a lot of CPU power
and it's in a very very small container
so we need to work with this new
technology the working environment is
changing we got different working
practices we tend to focus more on
teamwork rather than individuals I have
known people that literally work in a
box and they don't want to communicate
with anyone elses want to do their own
things and so the do you wear a headset
playing music when you're developing
code I see a lot of people like to do
that but does it mean that you're not
going to be meaning more to
communication what's interesting thing
whether but the environment is to change
its environment involving and companies
need to evolve as well
then we got all of the sorts of external
influences so depending on the
technology or domain you're in the news
headlines can make a big impact on your
domain there's all sorts of other
processes the legal process some areas
particularly finance are very heavily
regulated and the law keeps changing
then you have to adapt to it and certain
attitudes change as well so think about
these different influences and how does
the devops role address these issues
address change changes importance to
change is inevitable
so we need to build a culture and
maintain it so how do we do that
and again if all about continuous change
continually changing to react to the
things of the challenge that we've got
new technology do we use it new laws do
we do we have to address those ok
and so the organization's need to change
as well but people don't like change so
I give you an example I recently did a
sassy a Python course and there was a
guy on the course who he's very
experienced and I started introducing
some of the ideas that we were using
like test-driven development and has
developed code
he was absolutely mortified the whole
thing he says you've just turned
everything I've ever known and
understood and believed on its head and
he was really genuinely shocked by this
and because he had he was kind of
resistant to change
he'd done things in a certain way and
until he would always be able to do it
that way and people we need to work
together so don't sitting there in a
corner not speaking to anybody else I've
actually worked with people who kind of
so possessed of their code that if
somebody else sees it or changes it they
disowned it actually worked with someone
that like that it's very very difficult
to to work as that he couldn't work in
the team he was totally incapable of
working as a team member
now software tools cause all sorts of
issues many organizations particularly
large organizations have got where they
are by means of acquisitions and mergers
with other organizations every time two
organisations merge the chances are that
their teams will be using different
technologies and so it starts to
diversify how did you get it seems to
have used the same tools that's quite
difficult because you would have get
people to change the way they've been
working and use the different things and
learn the new things we've got open
source tools but some organizations
refuse to use open source tools because
they feel the need to pay somebody to
give them support ok we're going to look
at open source tools as long as you keep
the control of the versioning you're ok
the biggest problem you had can have
with open source tools is every team has
a different version at the same tall
assertions tend to change quite rapidly
so we have some kind of standardization
of tools across the organization there
are certain things like nicely begun
compliance is a major issue I was
actually talking to the person in charge
of compliance for a large bank her job
was a nightmare because what she had to
do is make sure that all the tools used
by all the teams were properly licensed
and they weren't doing it illegally and
so it was a complete nightmare
I actually explained to her about an
initiative in the organization which is
trying to sterilize things and she was
really happy about this she thought it
was great because it makes her life
easier because she she only needs to get
beat the lights for one set of
organizations rather than across very
large numbers and versioning Dinka
possibilities to get problems with that
if you get different versions of the
same tool there may be issues that if
something will start working you want to
make sure that when you use tools for
your or for your actual application that
the reduction support for them the
production support people need to be
able to support the tools if they can't
then the developers have to do it and
then there's the maintenance of support
needs also its own tools again there's
plenty of them and which ones you use
and I using the right ones alright
should you be using something more
sophisticated there's also the problem
of compatibility many organizations have
legacy systems I found that the banking
domain is one of the interesting ones
many banks are using really old
technology sort of COBOL programs as
have been around for decades and they're
not going to change them other
organizations use the very latest tools
all the time and keep updating and
constantly changing and it varies
considerably across the different banks
but you need to make sure that if you
introduce new tools it can work with the
old systems there are ways around this
you've got hybrid environments you can
have wrappers around things that enable
a legacy system to look like it's
something more up-to-date typically it's
something like a restful web front-end
to it now cloud solutions are getting
increasingly attractive because you've
got basically organizations such as
Amazon and Google and Microsoft who are
invested heavily in infrastructure and
they are good at what they do they
provide you with the raw computing power
and resources you need maybe with
solutions and it's a cheaper option in
many ways and having your own build that
means that tools must be ready to be
deployed to the cloud and of course
older new systems need to work together
and production need to be able to
support both
networking is also a difficult subject
what's our network connectivity looks
like corporate networks are complex
we've got local area networks we've got
data centers how do we get to the data
centers do we need to collect the cloud
and how to do that
you've got virtual LANs across sites
then all the sorts of things like
mapping port numbers IP addresses
firewalls bruce's things that can cause
blocks and complications
so the networks the topologies of
networks they're very very complex
indeed so changing networks
configurations is complex you're lighter
disconnect something vital if you do
that cloud computing can help this quite
considerably they're quite simple and
active all they've got all sorts logging
in there and they're secure so for
example we're going to be looking at
Google compute engine for the the labs
by default you can't get anywhere near
your virtual machines in the cloud from
the outside you have to open up the
firewall rules and we will actually be
doing that to enable you to connect to a
virtual machine on the set on the cloud
from the outside you have to make sure
that it's accessible
now we of course the cost comes into its
new hardware costs when you think you
need to think about software licenses if
you're using the cloud how's the cloud
provider charge for the resources you're
using you need to train and retrain your
your staff and while people learning new
skills they're not sort of productive
but still expected overhead so you need
to obviously have a budget for this but
the result is that you improve
efficiency in quality it's a long-term
objective or a longer-term objective so
introducing DevOps it's not more about
writing new applications in many
organizations it's very rare that you
get to write a new application you have
to maintain an existing one or enhanced
in some way so we've got these ideas you
had a new tool does it support the
legacy code so you can usually deal with
it in some way you can wrap it in
something you can restructure in some
way you might need to be able to
refactor it and we need to be able to do
all new developments and bug fixes using
new tools and procedures as we go
forward
okay to that reflection we've got a
knowledge check there what's the
cultural challenge of DevOps keep people
in to learn new languages people need to
work together across traditional role
boundaries people need to work different
hours people need to move tests
frequently it's looking very consistent
there yep
that's lots of bees yeah people need to
work together across traditional role
boundaries and for making how many
organizations are very sort of
monolithic in that respect okay I
actually work for a company if it was a
few years ago and I was working in
operations support I was million
managing web servers and application
servers I had to deal with the database
administrators for DBAs quite frequently
because I had to commit to databases I
was not allowed to talk to the DBAs
directly to get something done I had to
go through a formal mechanism involving
sending emails to a and she had mailbox
and even though I knew very well that
the person it would be answering my
query was that right behind me but I
wasn't allowed to talk to her directly
unless I've gone through the formal
process so we need to kind of get around
some of these things I've worked for
other organizations it's worth getting
to know the DBA ok I need this done
check for DBA oh yeah I'll do it for you
no problem if they understand that the
role that you've got crosses boundaries
which is often the case
so let's have a look at some other
software tools that give someone kind of
overview of them we have the concept of
a tool chains a kind of interesting
terminology isn't it but what we need to
do is select the right tools and each
stage of the software development
lifecycle or has potentially got its own
category of tools some might be maybe
spanning different ones but most of them
are very specific to a certain area and
then you're going to choose which
particular tool you're going to use for
or any particular phase and they need to
work together they might need to be
integrated in some way so for example if
you've got a continuous integration
server and a source control system you
need to connect them together so is it
possible to do that
so looking at the requirements stage of
things we've got all sorts of things
there like we've got where process is
fairly obvious share calendars without
wiki UML diagram in tools spit
management tool so a lot of people use
low-tech solutions to agile sprints I do
like the piece of card and whiteboard
approach and then you've got issue
intelligent systems where you put ticket
into the system and assigned to
individuals to get the control over
what's going on co-development covers a
huge range of technologies so we got all
these different technologies everything
from databases to editors compilers IDs
testing frameworks various database
mapping frameworks api is like REST API
is code quality tools which I think are
very important code reviews build tools
lots of different things and that's just
in the development cycle so there's a
huge range of tools in that one they're
sort of got an entire section on that
particular set of tools artifact
creation tools that Safari word is in
there artifact artifact is just
something that she's generated as part
of the process so typically we've got
things like source control systems that
you were very important continuous
integration tools to make sure that we
don't break the build and if we do we
know very quickly about it the actual
build tools themselves with the ones
that actually make the software make the
end results binaries or deliverables and
documentation gathering so that we can
extract information about what's going
on for documentation purposes
testing there's plenty of test tools
we'll be looking at unit tests and
mocking frameworks a few times scripting
is always very very important for
automating various process particular
useful for some of the cloud operations
building test harnesses so that we can
automate tear and you've got things like
user interface playback tools where you
would say simulate the use of a website
for test purposes we've got lost
test and these tools are all acquired at
different stages so things like them J
unit for unit test is also useful
integration tests that can be used for
integration tests as well as unit tests
packaging tools we've got there is
repositories where we store things like
libraries and deployed applications
we've got that also building the
applications container management tools
if you're going to use container
technology we are going to look quite a
lot at container technology using docker
because it's very very popular and
gaining momentum at the moment it's a
great way of dealing with many problems
just package the part of the application
or the whole application into a
container and just deploy it somewhere
maybe even in the cloud and then we've
got things for generation deployment
descriptors to integrate code with them
service
release management change moment systems
and approval systems how do we roll back
a release into production if it doesn't
work automating the release there's
various tools for doing this you just
publish a new version of it and it will
replicate it across the wherever it is
deployed scheduling tools for making
sure all the components run in the right
time in the right sequence and got
things like enterprise integration tools
where basically messaging systems and
how to control messaging
configuration and moistening there's
various infrastructure configuration
tools imagine tools the concepts of
infrastructure is code basically the
infrastructure is controlled by a set of
scripts or executables tracing requests
performance monitoring looking at log
files looking for things that there
shouldn't be in there was things that
should be in there reporting issues
those sort of tools are another set okay
so that's that section on software tools
so the knowledge check which phase will
contain the management tools be required
release cache packaging or code
development all right everybody seems to
think it's e and yes she is packaging
this how you sector PLC units of
deployment put it into a container and
off it goes as a deliverable right so an
overview of cloud computing now moving
into the cloud actually is a very
popular solution which many
organizations are starting to adopt and
there were a number of different clouds
he probably had experience of some of
them and it has got its advantages very
simple just to give an example I've got
some development work I need to do at
the moment I've got a laptop here which
I want to update to I want to install
the latest version of Debian Lion Debian
Linux on it and realized the time it's
going to take to download the image
install it and get everything up and
running
I could just create an instance of a
Debian Linux machine in Google Cloud in
a matter of seconds it'll save me a lot
of time so that's
probably the way I'm going to go I think
the laptop might go back in the garage
so think about it
traditionally organizations have had
data centers now data centers are
problematic
they're expensive both sub runs
maintained just think about it
you could have a building and buildings
need maintenance and you got to buy the
building in the first place you think
gotta buy all the hardware required for
your data center that's going to be
large numbers of computers disks
networking components all sorts of stuff
there and that's gonna be expensive
then you need to power it and they
dissenters use a lot of power have you
got the availability of that power you
need to have some special power lines
run into it and anything that generates
a lot uses a lot of power generate a lot
of heat so how you going to call it have
you got a local River you can use or
some other mechanism then you've got a
situation is the actual physical
security you've got to stop people from
getting into your data center and
causing problems then you want to make
sure that you can connect your data
center in a very high-speed way and your
data centers can connect to each other
for doing failover and backups and stuff
then you can have people to maintain
everything and then you're going to have
to have security issues for security
teams you know have policies how to
secure your place physically and how do
you secure your software there's lots of
different issues here which is quite a
lot of work to get this right let's give
an example here of just what the
situation is so think about the mean
time between failure of a harddrive your
average SATA hard drive I so the mean
time between failure of about 1.2
million hours it's about four years I
think that number and for most people
hard drives very rarely fail you have a
hard drive in the computer if I think
about hard drives failing I think I can
remember in the last maybe 20 years two
hard drives failing on me
and a fairly rare experience clearance
for an individual now take a data center
data centers got a hundred thousand hard
drives if you do the statistics you can
expect two drives to fail every single
day on average just the statistics so
what does that mean well for start off
you've got to make sure you've got a
couple of dozen drives constantly
available for replacement and you need
to constant replace those once a turn
failed and also replace the ones that
are ready to replace them you've got to
make sure you got mirror and failover so
when the drive does fail you don't lose
any data if then you're going to be able
to find the offending disk now inviting
the data center with 100,000 hard drives
how do you find the one that failed
where is it physically located then you
could have the maintenance team sync
were to be able to detect the problems
find the offending drive and replace it
and then you've got to be able to
destroy the failed disk because even
though the disks failed it doesn't mean
the data's lost so that means you're
going to have to do something like
effectively destroy it physically blow
itself or something or rise up to high
speed and then smash it it's something
that just completely destroys the data
and that's quite a a chance to do that
as well because physically destroying
the hard drive is actually quite
difficult
so what a cloud platforms all about then
well basically the cloud providers have
invested very heavily in infrastructure
I dread to think how much they've
actually spent in terms of the
datacenters so if you think the could
play the Google cloud end platform which
we're going to be using when you sign up
to it you choose a region a geographical
region which you will actually have to
do you'll have to find the one that's
nearest to you to avoid the latency
issues and there's about half a dozen
regions each region has got maybe three
or four different sets of functionality
so when you suggest
so that's your infrastructure you say I
won't say Western Europe see of which
there is Western Europe ABC and D it
doesn't matter which one you pick
you choose the one in my case I happen
to be in France so Western Europe here's
a good one for me
but you have to choose which one you
want so they've got a lot of these and
then each of those areas will have
several data centers associated with it
wherever they happen to be located so
they've invested very heavily in this
it's highly scalable it's very secure oh
it's very reliable they've done all the
hard work then they provide you with all
these services like stories royal rajesh
storage raw computing power services
really pre-built things platforms so you
can get a pre-built platform which not
certain things like certain operating
systems and operating systems with
certain applications running on them
then you also got applications
themselves so the quantum for services
they provide but what they do is they do
something really well they provide an
environment where you can build a
computing environment a computer in the
cloud which is just fair and works did
have to worry about any of the other
details there's one of the most
important things do something very well
extremely well a good example is the
UNIX operating system the UNIX has been
around since the late 1960
it's a very long time it's kind of
prehistoric area in terms of the IT
world and UNIX is running the vast
majority of computers today many servers
a UNIX maxie UNIX all most mobile phones
are UNIX we fix Android or iOS it's UNIX
that operating system is running the
world how come because basically it was
designed so that it's a loss of small
components that do something extremely
well and nobody out of beat it since
so that the cloud could be forgot the
data centers say they're geographically
distributed that may use problems it may
be a legal requirement that your data
lives in a certain place so for example
if you've got an organization in the
United States you probably have to have
your data in the United States and so
you need to make sure you you meet those
requirements you've got to be able to
have access point anywhere they're
pretty much and the data centers have to
be interconnected by very high speed
networks so they've invested heavily in
their infrastructure and they've got
many cloud vendors and actually invested
heavily in it and they've got their own
fibre network which links their data
centers together the concept of edge
caching as well where you actually store
things at the entry point to the cloud
to speed up the look of it basically if
somebody wants a read out in the
operation and submit they've already got
if it's cash on the entry point then you
don't have to go and find it inside the
cloud
so we have various terminologies here
worked the first one is infrastructure
as a service or IaaS this is basically
raw computer power
it's CPUs its disk storage it's
networking and what you do is you
specify what you want your computer to
look like I want it to have two CPUs I
want it to have 200 gigabytes of hard
drive storage and I need to be networked
with an external IP address and you just
dial it in into a web page or using the
command line you specify exactly what
you want a couple of minutes later
you've got a computer and they just
charge you for what you use
so basically what happens is when you
build your computer you're actually
allocating resources within the cloud
environment and you're basically tying
them up so that nobody else can use them
so what the idea is then that they the
cloud provider will charge you for what
components you use and so what you can
do though is release the components to
the cloud vendor when you no longer
require them so if what you think about
it you're basically renting the
components of your computer for the time
you need them and so you can actually
change it so you can say build yourself
a computer say actually only was CPU
power so we just haven't the CPU and so
what happens is the price goes up a bit
but it's not much we're literally
talking a few cents per hour for a
fairly powerful computer in the cloud
it's not expansion at all and and some
things like for example if you say I
want an external IP address on your
computer and this is something maybe
worth making you note of you when we
build our computers to be shortly in the
cloud you will say I want an IP address
now I external IP addresses ipv4
addresses are in short demand and so
what happens is you only have an
external certainly visible IP address
when your machine is running so what
happens is when you stop the machine the
IP address is released and goes back
into a pool so every time you start your
server you would potentially get a
different IP address so when you come to
do things where you've got the client or
maybe your local machine and you're
talking to a server in the cloud
remember the IP addresses like it's
changed every time you do to move to a
new exercise because they've reallocated
the resource
so we've got platform to serve as a
service paas so what you've got is
pre-configured runtime environments
typical things like operating systems so
you say I want a Debian 8 machine you
just say that's what you want you just
specify what hardware you want and then
they'll give you the actual machine and
you just pay for the resources you use
and they you provide the actual code
that should be executed in the
environment software as a service
this is pre-built application so you
want a web server rather than build
yourself a virtual computer and
installing Apache or nginx honest you
just say to the cloud provider I want a
web server based on Apache and they will
push me one the idea then what you do is
you pay the network traffic and storage
and other things but again it's not
expensive and and it's almost certainly
cheaper than maintaining your own
environment ok so now we have the first
exercise so how it works with the
exercise is fish I'm going to give you a
URL on the chat in a moment because what
we've got is all of our exercises are on
a github account and so I will give you
the URLs to the instructions for each
exercise and they will tell you what to
do sometimes legal involves checking out
a repository on the from the github
account other times it will just be
following instructions so what we're
going to do is this we're going to set
up an environment in the using Google
cloud platform now you should have been
sent an email saying about this ideally
you should have a gmail account I think
it's not technically necessary but it's
probably more reliable if you have a
gmail account so it doesn't take long to
set well not if you
- and then what you need to do is
register with Google and to do that you
live in told this as well you need to
have a credit card to prove who you are
it's purely as proof identity you're not
going to get charged because what
happens is the moment you sign up for
Google as a new subscriber they will
give you $300 worth of credit for free
okay now I just give you a word of
warning you may get an alert that Google
has debited $1 a whole dollar from your
credit card if they do that they will
immediately refund it so don't worry
about it they're not really going to
take any money off you they're just
checking that the card salad if actually
that may be the case so what we going to
do is they do that and then there's a
Debian virtual machine which is stored
in a in a bit bucket which we're going
to extract and install on our local
environments so I'll give you the
instructions and we're always connect to
it using the secure shell ssh right so
these are either URL to the instructions
if you just click on that link and go to
it and do this exercise I think it'll
probably take about 45 minutes so we'll
aim to resume in about 45 minutes I'd
appreciate it if you could just notify
me with that done in the chat when
you've actually finished and I get some
idea for who has finished new present
and if you've got any questions just
message me I'll be monitoring the chat
during the exercise if you since that
exercise and set up your environment
you'll also be installing the build tool
called maven
which is going to save a bit of time
later on
you
good example if tcp/ip stack unix solved
the problems of tcp/ip many years ago a
good example then was later on Microsoft
came along and reinvented the tcp/ip
stack they introduced bugs with UNIX of
self years ago and what they've done is
effectively rediscovered many bugs so
why not use something that's known to
work modify to your uses and these days
we try and use existing solutions
wherever possible it's easier and
cheaper to use them and when I stood up
is working solution and try and build
your own passwords are very classic
things I've heard stories where people
have gone into organizations using
software such as crack which is able to
try and break passwords in many
organizations with a bit of firm
advanced knowledge you can get a very
high percentage I've heard numbers like
80 percent so how it works is that
people often use passwords which are
very insecure dates of birth dates of
loved ones birth people's names
car registration them there's common
words if the organization favors a
particular football team the names of
the players if you go into an
organization you first of all go walking
around the car park and make a note of
all the registration numbers of the cars
you then find out any information about
popular things in the organisation you
create a database and you probably get a
lot of passwords now passwords are
typically stored as a one-way hash they
apply an algorithm which turns an
arbitrary string into a fixed length
string based on some algorithm
unfortunately there are ways around this
we have the concept of a rainbow table a
rainbow table is typically a website
where they've calculated the hashes of
all possible combinations of numbers and
letters up to a certain length you put
the hash into the rainbow table and
it'll come up with the password and this
rainbow tables for common in hashing
algorithms
one way of securing a password is to use
a salt what happens is you generate a
random number of a fixed size and you
append the password then you generate
the hash and then you append the salt to
the hash what happens there is this that
if two people have the same password by
coincidence the salt will pretty much
guarantee that their hash will be
different and so that also defends
against rainbow table attacks because
effectively you've got to multiply all
the combinations of numbers and letters
by all the possible combinations of the
salt which makes it much harder to do to
build the actual rainbow table how do
you make a secure password there are
various ways one I quite like if you
take two short unrelated words and
separate them with some numbers and
punctuation symbols it's very hard to
break that kind of password and they're
fairly easy to remember as well and
they're all so mechanism way you can
store passwords in various places and
they'll generate artificial passwords
it's a very difficult to break and you
just look them up when you need them
there's also secure ID and the idea of
that is that you've got a device which
enables you to authenticate yourself if
you should use by organizations where
you would want to allow employees to log
into the internal site from a remote
location such as from home or on the
road so what happens is the device
itself has a clock and it has a
pseudo-random number sequence which is
generated based on the clock so every
second every minute typically the the
random number sequence generate another
number there's typically quite a long
number so every minute that number
changes the server has a clock as well
and the database of all of the
algorithms which drive the devices so
you register device - server so the mean
first server can reproduce the number
that's displayed on the device at any
one time
typically it's using conjunction with a
personal identification number a pin
and you put the pin number followed by
the token and that will authenticate you
one problem is that the clocks
particularly on the devices themselves
security devices often drift so that
means that you need to do some kind of
Correction and the server's often have
drift value so they know how much the
actual device is going to drift so it
can compensate the time to make sure the
clock so in sync then of course is
biometrics fingerprints retinal scans
face recognition a lot of airports use
these types of things aren't they the UK
airports used to use retinal scans which
I thought was great they stopped using
them unfortunately but now they've moved
to the EU face recognition system so you
just point yourself at the at the
scanner and it recognizes you based on
the RFID the story your password so
voice prints typing patterns all sorts
of things which are typically unique for
a particular individual
so information security many
organizations have intersect teams or if
they see two teams they're important
talk to them they really want to talk to
you and people think that they're kind
of blocking you or causing problems and
they don't really want to talk them but
all the intersect guys I've met have
been really nice and they want to talk
to you because if you can if they can
detect a problem early by talking to you
it makes their life easier
they don't have to solve a problem if a
security breach and they don't have to
spend a weekend in the office when
they'd rather be at home so talks these
guys they're definitely interesting talk
to you because they want to make their
life and your life easier okay so the
knowledge check what if segregation Duty
require several inches to the beta
sensitive operation children could
perform or operations only one person
can perform any particular sensitive
operation given into several different
roles
yes yes we say require several entities
to complete a census operation okay so
now we're going to do is have a look at
requirements and something that's quite
important to look at requirements
analysis and user stories she's often
got wrong so the requirements basically
describe what a system is supposed to do
the requirement document describes
exactly what the end user or Clark
customer wants the system to do and how
it's is function and it's a
documentation system you need to
document it and say what it does
gathering requirements is quite
difficult it's industry process first of
all we need to find the problem then you
need to extract the requirements from
this and it's not the same as design
it's often confused design is to all
about how things work these are all
about what it does nothing else only
what so gather information analyze the
information start to extract the
requirements functional requirements are
probably the most interesting
particularly from the DevOps perspective
or the developers perspective anyway
this is basically what the system does
and there's four parts to it
you've got the process in the middle
which effectively at this stage is just
a black box we don't care what it does
or how it does it all we need to know
four things what the initial stage of
the system is what inputs we apply to it
and then having the process execute what
is the final state of the system and
what are the outputs that's all we need
to know okay but you need all four to be
specified otherwise the requirement is
incorrect and be careful here because
this is where assumptions often creep in
and assumptions may not be valid
face requirements you've got to
interface your system to other processes
other machines other components so what
the face requirements is do is specify
the inputs on the outputs the process
they may be integration requirements as
well if they going to be communicating
between systems and also interfaces to
users a user interface requirements will
show another flavor of interface
requirements
user interface requirements are probably
that one of the trickiest ones typically
requirements document may contain some
kind of information may be some kind of
wireframe diagram describe what it looks
like the one thing that's important is
this diagram here you've got there is
just capturing information saying this
information must be present on the user
interface and maybe these controls must
be present on the user interface it
would definitely not look like that
because the user interface looks
absolutely dreadful it's just simply a
vehicle for specifying the layout
information what you'll do later on is a
proper user interface design which is a
completely different process and a very
important process this will just show
you what the user interface should
contain
integration requirements so this is all
sorts of all sorts of inputs and outputs
where two things come from whether
things go to typically other systems or
individuals so you need to know for
every source and destination what kind
of data is flowing what speeds what
protocols are being used access to
database of all kind data volumes a
networking requirement speed
connectivity if you're interfacing to
third-party components you need to know
exactly how to do that typically it's
going to be some API involved and it's
not a requirements it's an architectural
specification architecture is all about
how things communicate with each other
requirements is exactly what they do
performance requirements another one
specify how the system behaves so for
example you get capacity the number of
parallel operations that could happen
we've got availability measured those
things they're mean time between failure
which we looked at with those hard
drives mean time to restore from a
problem than the availability of that
equation there then we've got the
response time how longs it take between
receiving an input and getting the
output throughput is the amount of data
that's actually throwing for the system
assumptions we've touched on things
before were they are important
assumptions something that you've just
as the name suggests you've said this is
true this this statement is true with no
justification they're often not stated
that is bare so first of all if you find
an assumption something is implicitly
there make sure it's stated and justify
it why do you make this assumption is it
valid the remember assumptions are
absolutely everywhere it occurs
throughout any set of requirements and
all sorts of places that you need to
make sure that you understand them and
not just and challenge them if you don't
believe in assumptions valid go talk to
somebody about it
jargon is a good one what is jargon my
jargon is actually important it enables
individuals within an organization to
communicate with each other
unambiguously like it's a Delaine
domain-specific language if you talk
about any natural languages they're very
very ambiguous so the English language
is notoriously ambiguous you've got
various words which many people
misinterpret the ones that are most
commonly occurred as far as Overson in
terms of English is it the two words
envious and jealous if you say I'm going
on a holiday to the Caribbean people
will say I'm jealous they're not they're
envious there's two words makes me
different envies when you you somebody
has something you think you should have
all you'd like to have jealousy is when
you afraid to lose something valuable
that somebody else could take away from
you they're very closely related but the
different lawyers don't use punctuation
often capital letter a full stop putting
a comma in a sentence can change the
meaning I can think of quite a few
sentences and so I won't quote right now
we're changing a comma or changing that
the capitalisation can change the
meaning of the sentence dramatically
so lawyers don't do it they can't stand
ambiguity can't be allowed so but jargon
is in language between peers which
enabled them to communicate with each
other without any mission understanding
whatsoever it's probably not
understandable way external people so
you have to be careful who you use it to
the other thing is developers must think
in the domain okay I often ask the
question of bankers are you an a banker
who have a developer or you a developer
who works for a bank the answer really
needs to be the former you're a banker
who also helps to be a developer you
need to understand that it may in to be
able to communicate with people in it to
produce the right results but only use
jargon where the audience understands it
at most for example production support
people will not understand jargon so
don't put it in log files they won't
understand it so how do you measure the
quality of requirements
well the certain metrics you can use
first of all requirements are not the
same as design requirements should be
testable requirements should be complete
it should be clear and understandable
consistent and traceable if you can meet
those quality metrics then you're in a
good place
so what happens if your requirements are
incomplete which is nearly all were
documents they're inconsistent
incomplete or just downright wrong
so first of all don't try and resolve
the issues okay I think I know enough
about this I can fill in the gaps and
and then get on with it no she's not
your job you need to talk to the
customer or business analyst through the
problem and say look I found this
inconsistency what's the real story the
way of dealing with this is to have an
interview with the person concerned and
there's various ways of conducting the
interviews and just be careful about
these things if you're talking to
certain people they might be very busy
and they don't want to suffer any any
rubbish questions to make sure you're
well prepared before you talk to people
and have a very clear idea of what you
want to achieve we go into the interview
you can have a strategy interview where
you write the questions in advance and
have effectively a script good for
surveys and certain other things and if
you know exactly what you want
unstructured if you're not really sure
you give you ask a question which is a
fairly open-ended one and then you probe
the answer and for qualification
requires bit more skill so you got open
and closed questions they're open
questions yeah what what do you think
you want to do with this or close
questions exactly what does this do what
should this do
different types of interview questions
situation why you want to do this what's
the vision problem what you trying to
solve and fix implication what's the
impact of the solution what's the
benefits what's the cost of anything
other ones like what's the priorities
which ones should we do first
whiskey the beers payoff so requirements
is important so what is not true about
assumptions they must be eliminated
they're everywhere they need to be
justified they need to be documented
mainly age-related they must be
eliminated
they shouldn't be eliminated they are
everywhere they do need to be justified
and they do need to be documented so
architecture architecture is basically
the glue that buildings putting together
typically a modern application consists
of a number of components which need to
be connected together so here are a
number of definitions it's the same idea
we need to do some kind of connection
typically architecture for most
organizations is some kind of messaging
system
the architecture involves all sorts of
things with stakeholders for business
goals the infrastructure because the
instructors could have implemented it's
got to achieve the business goals and
the stakeholders have got to be
satisfied if it's basically some kind of
messaging system to enable things to
communicate
so simply an ikea ikea architecture has
rules guidelines patterns you've got
pieces of solution then in treat pieces
you need to connect them together
communications you need to understand
the data flow you need to integrate
systems and you need to develop modules
based on the good practices we're going
to look at and of course you couldn't
manage the control deliver in the system
and the components of the system into
the environment so comparing
architecture with design once we get
one's tactical you're asking the
question how for architecture rather
what you are solving architectural
patterns rather than low level design
patterns and algorithms architecture is
non-functional requirements estate this
architecture is going to be used design
work on the functional requirements and
there's there is UML diagrams associated
with each spawn will look at UML in a
later exercise lesson
so various high-level architectures have
client-server which is quite commonly
stated we typically our thick clients
which has almost the code and network
and some kind of data storage at the
back
so what even tears it separates the user
interface from the central data layer
we've got reusable components security
is actually always a pro and a con we
can optimize infrastructure uses because
it's just actually in data and it's
scalable the disadvantage is if the
requirements change you've got to change
everything security is also a problem
because you have to deal with the
security the traffic and other things if
the data later goes down database goes
down you've lost everything a single
point of failure has you tested that's
always difficult and you've also got
presentation and business was in the
same place which really should be
separated so then we have the n-tier
architecture multi-tier typically N
equals 3 it gives us some a more
scalable solution presentation tier it
just got the user interface bit then we
got the business tier which does all the
stuff that makes the money then we got
the data access or integration tier
which does all the database interfacing
so it's scalable you don't need to
update the client code clients are often
very thin clients like a web server web
and web browsers and you don't need to
update a client when the business lot of
changes reduces the network traffic
because most of the traffic happens in
the middle and you can add extra layers
such as setting the layer between the
business candidates are accessed here
for
stored procedures and things like that
you can add layers at any point of ways
NT rather than three-tier so
disadvantages when requirements changes
how do you deal with that
there's always security implications
there's always availability and
reliability of servers and again how do
you test it
service-oriented architectures are SOA
these are becoming very very popular
these days so the great advantage is a
set of fairly unrelated pieces that talk
to each other to achieve a final result
so the main thing is the coupling is
loose that means that the each of the
individual services don't need to know
very much about each other if anything
at all if there have been interoperable
you can add new services across
different platforms without any problems
you don't care where the services are
you can reuse things you can put a front
end or a legacy application it'll join
the group it reduces development costs
and speed to market and it gives better
an integration with between business and
IT disadvantage a quite costly to change
to this architecture understanding it is
difficult the control system is not very
well understood and the sourcing and
monitoring is complex and you need the
best additional develop and design
support the hardest thing is actually
where are the services and how do they
interact are the biggest questions which
are very difficult to answer
so rest is very popular these days many
api's are based on it
it's basically what is the rest will
rest if the World Wide Web HTTP 1.1 the
protocol defines rest so the World Wide
Web
is that see the traditional restful
service it evolves it's all about
resources and not code you actually ask
for a resource and you get a
representation of you don't care what
the actual resource looks like you just
get a representation components can
evolve separately scalable you know
these micro services you do feel it it's
very easy to develop and you've got the
good use of data disadvantages the main
one disadvantages people really don't
know how to do it and the
infrastructures are not really in place
for handle it but it's getting better
a lycra service is just some service
that there's a very small job well okay
so rather than having a very big service
that does the whole application you have
a lot of small services as each to a
component of it
so there's also the four plus one on the
sectional view model which is quite an
interesting approach the idea is that
when you look at the architecture every
role in the organization sees a
different view of it so for example the
logical view is the end-user I want to
see how it works
development view how the software works
process view what the process is how
they talk to each other physical view
where are the processes on which
Hardware does it run and so you've got
four separate views - the idea is that
you construct the four views and then
you create the fifth view the +1 which
of the use cases which you're an
amalgamation of the four separate views
so you see things from four different
views four different aspects to produce
a single result okay so the nice check
what is architecture infrastructure
region is connect system components
system design fiscal layers of hardware
or set of functional requirements
okay I'm seeing out of age and say
infrastructure which interconnects
system components it's typically if you
want even a simplistic terms it's
usually a messaging system of some kind
some way of inter connecting services so
typically a JMS type system or it may be
a restful system but it's the messaging
system so final section in this lesson
is on user acceptance test and the
answer it we're asking the question have
we built the right thing now basically
the function requirements and have an
input state input values output state
output values then also describe the
test and so user acceptance tests
effectively test the functional
requirements from the requirements
document you should be able to write the
user acceptance test directly because
the function requirements define exactly
what it does
so when you're having written the user
acceptance s we have proved that we have
met all the function requirements and
the customer has got what they wanted
and they can pay us for it
so have you designed the EUR a UNT
environment ideally should be alone in
the production environment and so that
if they were changed in production
they're mirrored in the testbed this
means that you minimize the risks of
incompatibilities between the test
environment the production environment
unfortunately is not easily possible for
start off you probably haven't got the
resources the production environment
properly requires a lot of users and
very powerful hardware which you can't
do in tests so what you need to do is
function is to focus on functionality
don't look at performance this is not
the place to look at the performance you
do that in pre-production you might have
to fake external interfaces simulate
them you probably have to do popular
database with sample data typical a
snapshot of production data but that
might not be possible for example if the
production data has got sensitive
information like names and email
addresses and telephone numbers you
don't want this to get into the test
environments they caught may cause a
problem I actually worth one
organization they had the three
environments development UAC and
production and this system sent out
emails 500 in fact emails on every
operation the idea was in development
the emails disappeared they were just
thrown away in UAC they went to a shared
mailbox in production they went out to
the real world somebody accidentally
configure the development environment to
use the production email system and
somebody wrote a test message with an
extremely offensive it went out to 500
real customers very embarrassing just be
careful about that sort of thing
so think about sanitizing your data by
replacing email addresses which on fake
ones
so basically the use case is typically a
way of representing requirements have
initial conditions inputs outputs final
conditions that's exactly where a test
looks like the only difference being for
the use cases generically says a
customer selects a product code the UAC
must say that listen that the customer
selects this product code and gives an
explicit value for it so you must put
values in rather than just names for the
the placeholders you also need to make
sure that the database in a known state
before the the test and you also need to
execute use case in the right order
typically a use case can't be executed
in isolation many systems require an
authentication step and you can't do the
subsequent steps without the
authentication so you must execute the
use case for authentication first so
typically you have to find define a
sequence of use cases required to
achieve a particular test and you need
to specify the values at each stage you
also need to find specify what safe the
database should be at the end of the
test to show that the test has been
successful there's also things that
include things like screen layouts
instructions for entering ports and you
need to train these as to how to do the
tests
now this is important as well we've got
requirements we got user acceptance test
how do we prove that all the
requirements have been tested we
generated traceability matrix we specify
all the requirements around one axis or
the session another one and put the next
where the test tests the requirements if
there's a row or a column without an X
you know you've got a problem you've
either got a test which doesn't test the
requirement and he's redundant it should
be removed we're going to requirement
which isn't our test and need to have a
test applied to it
now requirements in agile software
development are specified in terms of
user stories the user stories need to be
testable so what is a good story look
like it's frozen action for a specific
user okay this particular user wants to
do something and this says you need to
specify who the target is
who is going to receive the result you
have very clearly stated acceptance
criteria which can be tested and the
story should be fairly small you don't
want the story to take more than a few
days to be implemented typically it's
half a day to a day and the story should
be short precise and unambiguous that's
quite an achievement very few people can
write good user stories let's meet all
those criteria
so for the case study here's an example
the user goes after doctor administrator
I need to be able to tailor list of all
containers at termination in last hour
the output web page needs to contain the
event type the container name the date
and time of eventual to reverse time
order okay is that I could use the story
do you think do you think it's a good
user story that's testable consensus not
sure it meets the basic requirements
it's concise you don't think so okay it
needs to basic employment
yeah it's precise it's testable it may
be elaborate a bit here it probably
needs the as a doctor administrator line
probably a little bit more qualification
yeah this is textbooks you can see what
you get to me in the results
okay so noise check what are user
acceptance tests just to verify that
every function requirement has been
implemented testing that the user
interface works testing the system
components work together testing user
interface usability okay yes the answer
is a test to verify that every
functional requirement has been
implemented okay so this is the the end
of this chapter key takeaways DevOps
requires cultural change we need to
improve ourselves constantly in terms of
equality and reliability things are
changing all the time technology and
other aspects there's a wide range of
tools and the wide range of options for
this also need to make a good decision
cloud computing is a good answer for
many things expensive data centers we
don't need them and cloud is actually a
good solution for many people
information security is very important
protect the assets and make sure that
things are done correctly architecture
defines communication and if you have
some stationing requirements but it's
not past requirements it's important
that requirements are completely
inconsistent
unfortunately they almost certainly
gonna change because that's the way of
the world the requirements always change
and use acceptance tests prove that
we've implements all the functional
quiet requirements correctly and we've
delivered the right thing and can get
paid by the customer
so now we have a quiz at the end of the
chapter so question 1 what is DevOps the
integrated development environment
collaboration between developers and
operations a formula software
development lifecycle or a coding
methodology lolly yeah very very swift
response there that's good yeah it'd be
a lab relation between developers and
operations we don't have them separate
roles it's something in between a bit of
both
what is defense in depth so firewall
designs trustee and encryption algorithm
the layered applications that limit
scope for intrusion right yep G
ii-if the answer lay in applications to
limit the scope so you penetrate one
layer you can't necessarily get to the
next one 3 what is the rainbow table
performance database construct cook
table of hashes of common passwords a
means of representing requirements or a
software date structure yeah
it's B it's a lookup table of hashes of
common passwords Chris for how do some
assumptions be treated they should be
justified documented they must be
eliminated
they're definitely implicit or they most
fun part of tests ok we're gonna mix
little responses there it's a they must
be justified document it you can't
eliminate them
there's always going to be assumptions
quiz 5 what is the traceability matrix a
dense structure the mechanism for
locating with my ease and design pattern
we're mapping between funds and
requirements in the UI T ok we cover the
census pair yes he said some mapping
between functional requirements in UAT
right so this is the end of the DevOps
overview lesson the next lesson is on
virtualization in library containers
we're going to introduce the concepts of
virtualization and we're going to
introduce you Jersey do you do introduce
you to Dhaka which is a very popular
implementation of lightweight containers
and we've got a number of exercises
around dakka dakka is going to be an
ongoing theme throughout the
presentation throughout the course so
now move - oops I'm missing something
just a moment
the final bit so all will always in this
on one of these
the first one is any questions the
question answers and have you got any
questions on anything we've covered
today okay
GSE tilt basically the Google cloud
platform works like this there's a user
interface which to the website which you
used there's also a set of command line
tools there that they are proprietary to
Google if you get the you can actually
install the GHGs utilities on your own
local machine and access the cloud so
when you did everything on the website
you could have done everything from the
command line on your local machine so
GSU tools utils if Google's one of the
Google security packages programs so
micro-service be simply a small service
that just one very restricted range of
application a range of functions very
well so it'd be something very specific
like it'll give you the exchange rates
between two currencies it doesn't do a
full application just as part of it okay
so also are we using docker lab or a PC
will be using docker on the virtual
machines in the cloud the reason for
that being that docker only really works
well on Linux there is a latest version
for Windows and for OSX but they're both
a bit broken so we need to do everything
will be done on the Google cloud virtual
machine we built earlier on today okay
you should have DevOps down the line
that's a good question
it's very hard to say the technology
it's not going to go away in fact it's
just taking off
I mean DevOps wasn't really
I heard of a few years ago now you
starting to see it all over the place
because again in the past developer
roles operation roles were separated and
the organization's enforce the
separation so yeah it's going to develop
and the tools are going to velop and the
processes are going to develop and the
way that the cloudy cloud environments
mean growing massively over the next few
years I think the different services
it's a difference at that at the level
so you have got everything from and when
it is something as a service we're
talking about whether it's just the raw
CPU disks storage is it going to be like
an operating system is it going to be in
a fully blown application yeah so
there's it's basically the level of the
amount of software that's on the the
service itself is it anything from rot
just raw story she built it from - a
complete fully blown application and
awareness of cloud you don't need to be
greatly familiar with cloud what we're
going to be doing is using cloud in a
very specific way if you look at the
Google cloud platform it has a lot of
different components and what we're
doing is really looking at one of them
we will be looking at how to configure
the compute engine more over the time
and we won't go into great detail on
other things like for example Google
cloud platform has got the bigquery it's
got the compute engine it's got the App
Engine we won't be looking at many of
those
principles yeah we're going to be
looking for principles definitely it's
all about good practices management
practices one thing DevOps practices I
have got a slightly different focus and
the DevOps practices are concerned with
doing the job well basically producing
quality solutions to problems and
basically eliminating problems in
production and later on their ops versus
no ops we're going to have operations of
some perform anyway the idea is that we
DevOps looking more at the automation of
the stages which did not develop that
developers are concerned with producing
code DevOps extends this role to the
tooling which enables you to do some of
the other stages there will be lab
sessions for every lesson it depends on
the lesson some of them have gots this
one only had one which is quite a long
one the next lesson has got three labs
which is shorter and the final lesson
has got seven loves said there are
actually 26 labs in total yeah this one
was the big one
getting the cloud platform up and
running we didn't really have any choice
that because it takes a little while to
get it working so this is probably the
heaviest lesson in terms of setting
things up others what might be the same
length but there'll be a lot more
involved with it
yes we have access you have access to
the presentation if you go to the LMS
which is on the website
simple own website I think it takes
about 24 hours but a you can download a
copy of the audio and visual for this
presentation because there basically in
recording this session so yes you can
read it
you've always got access to the it was
like this to the labs well if you want
to redo the labs feel free to try it so
if you have any problems with that lab
today feel free to redo it or who wants
to do anyway feel free to release it at
any time you want to write tomorrow or
in the way in the week for write the
labs in the coming sessions if you try
an action listen they can take it out of
context so the idea is that the labs are
there for a very specific reason okay I
can tell you that the next session is
going to be on virtualization so there's
going to be three exercises using docker
in various ways don't discard the VM
unless you've it's broken because you
need that VM what's going to happen is
over the eighth lessons you're going to
use that VM for all the exercises and
some of them will have dependencies so
for example the last step of the
exercise today was install to install
maven and they sure exercise is going to
assume you've already done that so keep
the VM just have it stopped then you can
restart it at the starter from the
exercises
okay any other questions okay remember
you've got access to simply talk and the
help and support they believe if you
have any issues and then this goes to
that site you can get copies you've got
the e-book you can download which is a
copy of the notes you've also can
download the recording of the WebEx
session so you've got all that stuff so
don't forget that's there boys do so at
the end of the session when I finish up
when you sign off it'll take you
straight to a website to filling the
evaluation appreciate if you do that the
way it works is we want you to be the
green guys at the end and so that's the
fee back if you want to group it with
you see development costs and speed to
market and it gives better an
integration with the between business
and IT disadvantage a quite costly
change to this architecture
understanding it is difficult the
control system is not very well
understood and the certain auditing and
monitoring is complex and you need the
best additional develop and design
support the hardest thing is actually
where are the services and how they
interact are the biggest questions which
are very difficult to answer
so rest is very popular these days many
api's are based on it it basically one
is the rest will rest if the World Wide
Web
HTTP 1.1 the protocol defines rest so
the world wide web is that see the
traditional restful service it evolves
it's all about resources and not code
you actually ask for a resource and you
get a representation of you don't care
what the actual resource looks like you
just get a representation the bonus can
evolve separately scalable you know
these micro services you do two bit it's
very easy to develop and you've got the
good use of data disadvantages the main
one disadvantages people really don't
know how to do it and the
infrastructures are not really in place
for handle it but it's getting better a
micro service is just some service that
there's a very small job well ok so
rather than having a very big service
that does the whole application you have
a lot of small services that each do a
component of it
so there's also the four plus one on the
sectional view model which is quite an
interesting approach the idea is that
when you look at the architecture every
role in the organization sees a
different view of it so for example the
logical view is the end-user I want to
see how it works
development view how the software works
process view what's the process how they
talk to each other physical view where
are the processes on which hardware does
it run and so you've got four separate
views - the idea is that you construct
the four views and then you create the
fifth view the +1 which of the use cases
which you're an amalgamation of the four
separate views so you see things from
four different views four different
aspects to produce a single result okay
so the nice check what is architecture
infrastructure region to connect system
components system design physical layers
of hardware or set of functional
requirements
okay I'm seeing out of age and say
infrastructure which interconnect system
components it's typically if you want
even in simplistic terms it's usually a
messaging system of some kind some way
of inter connecting services so
typically a JMS type system or it may be
a restful system but it's the messaging
system so final section in this lesson
is on user acceptance test and the
answer it we're asking the question have
we built the right thing now basically
the functional requirements and have an
input state input values output state
output values then also these try to
test and so user acceptance tests
effectively test the functional
requirements from the requirements
document you should be able to write the
user acceptance test directly because
the functional requirements define
exactly what it does so when you're
having written the user acceptance s we
have proved that we have met all the
function requirements and the customer
has got what they wanted and they can
pay us for it
so have you designed the EUR a UNT
environment ideally should be a clone in
the production environment and so that
if they were changing production they
mirrored in the testbed this means that
you minimize the risks of
incompatibilities between the testing
balance in the production environment
unfortunately it's not easily possible
for start off you probably haven't got
the resources the production environment
probably requires a lot of users and
very powerful hardware which you can't
do in tests so what you need to do is
funky focus on functional actually you
don't look at performance this is not
the place to look at performance you do
that in pre-production you might have to
fake external interfaces simulate them
you probably have to do up a database
with sample data typical a snapshot of
production data but that might not be
possible for example if the production
data has got sensitive information like
names and email addresses and telephone
numbers you don't want this against into
the test environments they caught might
cause a problem I actually worked for
one organization they had the three
environments development UAC and
production and this system sent out
emails 500 in fact emails on every
operation the idea was in development
the emails disappeared they were just
thrown out thrown away in UAC they went
to a shared mailbox in production they
went out to the real world somebody
accidentally configure the development
environment to use the production email
system and somebody wrote a test message
with an extremely offensive it went out
to 500 real customers very embarrassing
just be careful about that sort of thing
so think about sanitizing your data by
replacing email addresses with some fake
ones
so basically the use case is typically a
way of representing requirements have
initial conditions inputs outputs final
conditions that's exactly where a test
looks like the only difference being for
the use cases generically says a
customer selects a product code the UAC
must say that this and that the customer
selects this product code and gives an
explicit value for it so you must put
values in rather than just names for the
the placeholders you also need to make
sure that the database in unknown state
before the the test and you also need to
execute use case in the right order
typically a use case can't be executed
in isolation many systems require an
authentication step and you can't do the
subsequent steps without the
authentication so you must execute the
use case for authentication first so
typically you have to find define a
sequence of use cases required to
achieve a particular test and you need
to specify the values at each stage you
also need to find specify what safe the
database should be at the end of the
test to show that the test has been
successful there's also things that
include things like screen layouts
instructions for entering input and you
need to try any use as to how to do the
tests
now this is important as well we've got
requirements we got user acceptance -
how do we prove that all the
requirements have been tested we
generated traceability matrix we specify
all the requirements around one axis or
the test on another one and put the next
where the test testing requirements if
there's a row or a column without an X
you know you've got a problem you've
either got a test which doesn't catch
the requirement and is redundant and
should be removed we're going to
requirement which isn't our test and
need to have a test applied to it
now requirement in agile software
development are specified in terms of
user stories the user stories need to be
testable so what's the good used to look
like it's frozen action for a specific
user okay
this particular user wants to do
something and it says uniquely
specifying who the target is who is
going to receive the result you have
very clearly scheduled acceptance
criteria which can be tested and the
story should be fairly small you don't
want the story to take more than a few
days to be implemented typically it's
half a day to a day and the story should
be short precise and unambiguous that's
quite an achievement very few people can
write good user stories let's meet all
those criteria
so for the case study here's an example
the user goes after doctor administrator
I need to be able to obtain a list of
all containers at termination and last
hour the output web page needs to
contain the event type the container
name date and time of the event in
Reverse time order okay is that I could
use the story do you think do you think
he's a good user stories testable
consensus not sure it meets the basic
requirements it's concise you don't
think so okay it needs to based on
requirements yeah it's concise it's
testable it may be elaborate a bit here
it probably needs the as a doctor
administrator line probably needed to
get more qualification yeah these test
books you can see what you get to me in
the results
okay so noise check what our user
acceptance tests just to verify that
every function requirement has been
implemented testing the user interface
works caching the system components work
together testing user interface
usability
okay yes the answer is a test to verify
that every functional requirement has
been implemented okay so this is the the
end of this chapter key takeaways DevOps
requires cultural change we need to
improve ourselves constantly in terms of
the quality and reliability things are
changing all the time technology and
other aspects there's a wide range of
tools and the wide range of options for
the schools and these make a good
decision cloud computing is a good
answer for many things expensive data
centers we don't need them and cloud is
actually a good solution for many people
information security is very important
protect the assets and make sure that
things are done correctly architecture
defines communication and it's often
stationing requirements but it's not
past requirements it's important that
requirements are completely inconsistent
unfortunately they almost certainly go
change because that's the way of the
world the requirements always change and
use acceptance tests prove that we've
implemented all the functional quiet
requirements correctly and we've
delivered the right thing and can get
paid by the customer
so now we have a quiz at the end of the
chapter so question 1 what is DevOps
integrated development environment
collaboration between developers and
operations a form of software
development lifecycle or a coding
methodological sorry yeah very very
swift response there that's good yeah
it's B's
collaboration between developers and
operations we don't have them separate
roles it's something in between and a
bit of both
one is defense in depth so firewall
designs trustee and encryption algorithm
layered applications that let me scope
for an intrusion right yep
G he he answer layered applications to
limit the scope so you penetrate one
layer you can't necessarily get to the
next one
three what is a rainbow table a form of
database construct a cup table of hashes
of common passwords a means of
representing requirements or a software
date structure yep it's B it's a lookup
table of hashes of common passwords
Chris for how do some assumptions be
treated they should be justified
documented they must be eliminated
they're definitely implicit or they most
fun part of test okay we're gonna mix so
the response is there it's a they must
be justified a document it you can't
eliminate them there's always going to
be assumptions quiz five or what is the
traceability matrix a dense structure
and mechanism for locating with coinies
a design pattern or mapping between
functional requirements in uit okay we
cover the census pair yes he said some
mapping between functional requirements
than you eighty right so this is the end
of the DevOps overview lesson the next
lesson is on virtualization like my
containers we're going to introduce the
concepts of virtualization and we're
going to introduce you to Z you do
introduce you to darker which is a very
popular implementation of lightweight
containers and we've got a number of
exercises around dakka dakka is going to
be an ongoing theme throughout the
presentation throughout the course so
now move - oops I'm missing something
just a moment
the final bit so all will all within
this on one of these
the first one is any questions question
answers and have you got any questions
on anything we've covered today okay GSC
kills basically the Google cloud
platform works like this there's a user
interface which to the website which you
used there's also a set of command line
tools there that they are proprietary to
Google if you get the you can actually
install the do @gs utilities on your own
local machine and access the cloud so
when you did everything on the website
you could have done everything from the
command line on your local machine so
GSU tools utils if Google's one of
Google's utility packages programs so
microservice is simply a small service
that just one very restricted range of
application a range of functions very
well so it'd be something very specific
like it'll give you the exchange rates
between two currencies it doesn't do a
full application just as part of it so
also are we using docker or RPC will be
using docker on the virtual machines in
the cloud the reason for that being that
docker
only really works well on Linux there is
a latest version for Windows for OSX but
they're both a bit broken so we need to
do everything will be done on the Google
cloud virtual machine we built earlier
on today okay you should have gave up
stay on the line that's a good question
it's very hard to say the technology
it's not going to go away in fact it's
just taking off
I mean DevOps wasn't really
heard of a few years ago now you
starting to see it all over the place
because again in the past developer
roles operation roles were separated and
the organization's enforced separation
so yeah it's going to develop and the
tools are going to develop and the
processes are going to develop and the
way that cloudy cloud environments mean
growing massively over the over the next
few years I think the different services
it's a difference at that at the level
so you have got everything from and when
you see something as a service we're
talking about whether it's just the raw
CPU disks storage is it going to be like
an operating system is it going to be in
a fully blown application yeah so it's
basically the level of the amount of
software that's on the the service
itself is it anything from raw just real
stories you should building it from to a
complete fully blown application and
awareness of cloud you don't need to be
greatly familiar with cloud what we're
going to be doing is using cloud in a
very specific way if you look at the
Google cloud platform it has a lot of
different components and what we're
doing is really looking at one of them
we will be looking at how to configure
the compute engine more over the time
and we won't go into great detail on
other things like for example Google
cloud platform that's got the bigquery
it's got the compute engine it's got the
App Engine we won't be looking at many
of those
principles yeah we're going to be
looking for principles definitely it's
all about good practices management
practices one thing DevOps practices
I've got a slightly different focus the
DevOps practices are concerned with
doing the job well basically producing
quality solutions to problems and
basically eliminating problems in
production and laser on their ops versus
no ops we're going to have operations of
some perform anyway the idea is that we
DevOps looking more at the automation of
the stages which did not develop that is
developers are concerned with producing
code DevOps extends his role to the
tooling which enables you to do some of
the other stages there will be lab
sessions for every lesson it depends on
the lesson some of them have gots this
one only had one which is quite a long
one the next lesson has got three labs
which is the shorter the final lesson
has got seven loves so there are
actually 26 labs in total yeah this one
was the big one getting the cloud
platform up and running we didn't really
have any choice that because it takes a
little while scaling working so this is
probably the heaviest lesson in terms of
setting things up others what might be
the same length but there'll be a lot
more involved with it
yes we have access you have access to
the presentation if you go to the LMS
which is on the website simply learn
website I think it takes about 24 hours
but a you can download a copy of the
audio and visual for this presentation
because they're basically recording this
session so yes you can read it you've
always got access to the was like the
labs well if you want to redo the labs
feel free to try it so if you had any
problems with that lab today feel free
to redo it or who wants to do anyway
feel free to the repeat it at any time
you want to like tomorrow or in the wake
and then week for write labs in the
coming sessions if you try an action
listen they can take it out of context
so the idea is that the labs are there
for a very specific reason okay I can
tell you that the next session is going
to be on virtualization so there's going
to be three exercises using docker in
various ways don't discard the VM unless
you've it's broken because you need that
VM what's going to happen is over the
eighth lessons you're going to use that
VM for all the exercises and some of
them will have dependencies so for
example the last step of the exercise
today was install to install maven a
layer exercise is going to assume you've
already done that
so keep the VM just have it stopped then
you can restart it at the starter from
the exercises
okay any other questions okay remember
you've got access to simply talk and the
help and support they believe if you
have any issues so then this goes to
that site you can get copies you've got
the e-book you can download which is a
copy of the notes you've also can
download the recording of the WebEx
session so you've got all that stuff so
don't forget that's their choice to do
so at the end of the session when I
finish up when you sign off it'll take
you straight to a website to filling the
evaluation visit if you do that the way
it works is we want you to be the green
guys at the end and so that's the feed
back if you want to share the
information by win to do so that's
basically the the end of today's lesson
if you haven't got any of the questions
I'll call it a day
and it's quite late for some of you now
isn't it and we'll resume tomorrow at
the same time for the second lesson okay
okay so thank you very much and I'll
speak to you tomorrow
you